this week on the diver ceo we have a
returning guest
jake humphreys he is an entrepreneur he
is a tv presenter
he's also now a podcaster and jake has
spent the last
year on his podcast sitting down with
some of the most high performance
people some of the most accomplished
people in their industries from
acting to business to sports you name it
and so because of that experience
because of all the insights he's gained
over the last year since we last spoke
i wanted to sit down with him and
compare notes
we have a lot of high performance people
on this podcast too i wanted to
understand the similarities
i wanted to pick into the minds of some
of the guests and what he's learned from
them
how are they the same what makes them
different and that's what we're going to
talk about today so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
dire of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
you've um you've had what 30
people on your podcast today you've got
a lot more coming up
one of the key questions that i that i
wanted to ask you because it's you know
something that i asked myself
is what are those like key lessons that
you've learned you've interviewed
you know high performance athletes
actors
authors um and really sort of high
performance people
from all industries what are the key
lessons and the themes
i think there is one key lesson that was
summed up for me by
matthew mcconaughey the oscar-winning
actor who came on my pod
recently and his phrase is don't leave
crumbs
and what he means by that is like when
you're making a decision
don't leave stuff behind don't make a
bad decision now that later on you've
got to go back and pick that crumb up
and be regretful about it and
that's brilliant because sometimes when
we talk on the podcast we talk about
really like big
blue sky thinking you know like we've
talked to you about social change
setting up social change sometimes to
people that are listening and that can
seem like unreal almost untouchable
because it's this huge
multi-million dollar business that
you've created but actually
don't leave crumbs is about making the
decisions for a big
big business like that and creating
something amazing but also like
make sure that you don't have an extra
drink and even in case it leaves you
with a hangover tomorrow and you've got
work to do or make sure you
simply choose your clothes the night
before so you're not doing it in a rush
and
like i still leave crumbs all the time
like i'll tell you when we uh when we
interviewed matthew
like he's the first hollywood actor
we've had on the pod so for me it was
quite a big moment
and i thought i really want to be
looking good for this so i thought i'd
have a shower and a shave before we do
the interview
and i was having a shave in the bathroom
my wife was in the bath
and she was going to come down and like
listen in the corner in my study because
she was like
she loves dallas buyers club she was
excited and uh
she starts having a shave and she goes
it's 9 54.
i was like and i thought it was like 9
30 or something we put the kids to bed
and then the next thing i'm running
downstairs i haven't done my hair
properly
i'm on i've got two wi-fi zone because
our upload speed living in the
countryside is horrendous
so i was then on the wrong wi-fi i then
looked for the script i'd written for
the questions for matthew couldn't find
them
and i was like i was the last one in i'm
getting beaten to the interview on my
own podcast
by a hollywood actor and
i left crumbs and now that's a good
lesson for me because i do it all the
time and i think that
you only learn about the crumbs you
leave by doing it and i just
i just really want people i've had a few
negative comments that have come my way
about the podcast
direct messages from people saying um
you're getting this all wrong we're in a
global pandemic i'm having a really hard
year
and here you are with a podcast that's
just celebrating success all the time
and showing up
how um how we're all doing badly
compared to your great guests
and for me the podcast is a that hurts
me to think that
because i don't want anyone to come to
the high performance podcast and leave
in that way but it's the absolute total
opposite
of that because when we talk about what
lessons can you learn from people on the
podcast
the other biggest one is they mess up
all the time i think
i genuinely believe successful people
make more mistakes than anybody else
because they're
constantly challenging themselves to do
stuff and you you're no stranger to
making
decisions that at the time you just
simply don't know
but you have to find a way of making
that decision um
and i'm sure there are times when you've
made 10 or 15
life-changing decisions in a week you
know the the the point about those
crumbs
and you know rushing down the stairs
when you realize that you were like what
could you have done in hindsight to
um to prevent those crumbs being left
behind per se i just need to be really
honest with myself that i have
weaknesses and i need to address them
rather than thinking that everything's
fine and i am
notoriously late i am always a few
minutes late and always my new year's
resolution is this is the year
that i'm not going to be late is but it
just i'm surprised you know that you're
late
because um the industry you work in i
know
it's very and look at all the guests
i've had on my podcast we had um sir
clive woodward who won the rugby world
cup
and you think of all of the discipline
and the rules and the mindsets you need
to win
a rugby world cup the number one thing
that stands out for him is something
called lombardi time which was created
by the players
and they lombardi obviously is a famous
name in american sports and they call it
lombardi time because it's a name that
sort of resonates
with winning and it was 10 minutes early
so if you say to any former england
rugby player what's lombardi time
they'll tell you 10 minutes early so
listen
i'm hearing this stuff steven on a
weekly basis and still not getting it
right and i think it just goes to show
that we are human we have
we are fallible and i do think we have
blind spots which
there are some things some people find
really hard i don't there are some
things that is not an issue for other
people
and it is a recurring problem for me to
deal with
but no one's perfect and how do you
emotionally feel
about the fact that you have blind spots
in terms of like
do you beat yourself up about it yeah
yeah i think so
yeah um i think it's a really common
phrase isn't it to hear that you're your
own biggest critic
i think i'm probably less my own biggest
critic
than i was previously like when i
first started in my presenting career
and i used to come off air on the
formula one
i would solely focus on the bad stuff
on the issues on the problems and that
was instilled in me by david coulthard
because he'd step straight out of a
formula one car
straight into broadcasting and
tv is a friendly and lovely place to be
most of the time
you know we're really good at telling
each other how great we are and we had
our first production meeting
just after the first race and i was just
grateful to get through it it was my
first ever bit of
live formula one so i was just glad to
have survived so i was ready for this
lovely you were great you were great you
were great this was great
we started the meeting and david
coulthard went well sorry
can we just stop and that this is
unheard of he goes
i'm just not interested in this and the
producer was like sorry
i don't understand he's like i'm not
interested in sitting here and going
through all the good stuff
how does going through the good stuff
make the boat go faster
why are we not talking about the bad
stuff and that was a revelation from me
i was like yes the good stuff's already
good so you focus on the good stuff
now i have a different mindset and
bearing in mind
my first race was 2009 so this is 11
years ago
and for a long time my focus was on
the stuff that i was struggling with or
the stuff i wasn't very good at
or the times where i didn't feel life
was very good so i would look at a bad
month or a bad year and go right
why was i not flowing why was i not
really in a happy place why was this
why don't we focus more on the good
stuff and that is my mindset change that
is the thing that i
for 2021 that is going to be my focus
let's focus on the good stuff so we
realize what the good stuff is just do
more of it let's focus on the times when
you were flowing and when you were
feeling great
when you were barreling around the place
and when you were the guy and when
everyone wanted to work with you
what was i doing what was i eating how
was i sleeping
who was i spending my time with what was
feeding me what was making me feel
fantastic
that's probably a better place to focus
on i particularly after the sort of crap
2020 we've all had
i feel we've become a nation maybe even
a planet
with this light obsession on failure
to not fail anymore to be good and it's
almost like a badge of honor isn't it
like i'm sure if
you said to me three or four months ago
how's your relationship with failure my
love failure
love faith bring failure on that's how i
learn failures where i grow
i need to be on the absolute edge so i'm
failing all the time i want to fail
forwards and i want to fail often
like i still do but when i fail when i
leave crumbs when i'm late for an
interview with matthew mcconaughey
i'm not thinking why did that happen
because then i'm focusing on the failure
i will allow it to be there
and i will do my best not to do it again
but i'm gonna try for 2021 to think
about the good stuff man and just to see
how that changes things for me
super interesting you know do you focus
on your failure
um i i don't focus on the failure i
think i was just i was
actually asking myself that question
when you were talking i was thinking do
i am i someone that dwells on failure to
be fair i don't
i'm very very good at being detached
from it all i think i talked earlier in
this podcast about
this like um video game mentality that
i've taken on my life where
i see my my worst days
and to be honest a lot of them no i
think it's just my worst days as
if i'm playing a video game and that i
am
i am not what's happening and it's and i
i think that detachment from what's
happening
has allowed me in my most chaotic
moments
to remain calm it's allowed me to form a
sort of calm within my chaos so
if i have a big failure or i really
really [ __ ] up and i'm i'm disappointed
with myself or whatever
i'm very good at detaching from that um
so i think i think the absolute
absolute ownership of what you're doing
for me is powerful which is
is that the total opposite of what
you're saying because like whatever i do
i have to absolutely believe it and own
that decision because then if it goes
wrong or people question it i can say
listen i
really thought it was the right thing
it's like the emotional detachment it
means that
i'm not i don't think that i'm going to
die although i am totally responsible
for changing it so i can think of i'm
thinking
specifically about the day where um i
was driving to work
get get the emails and the text messages
saying that our whole server's been
hacked and every client we have has been
sent really
really personal specific abuse by them
from our email server
that's come from my business partner's
email that looks like it was meant to be
sent to my assistant
but the client was just accidentally ccd
and this happened this happened about
four years ago five years ago
so i'm driving to work and i'm getting
all these and in that moment
one has a choice whether they want to
fall into the problem and become the
problem and become consumed by it
or if they want to hold it out in front
of them and deal with it there
yeah if it consumes me i'll be crippled
with anxiety crying in the corner
but if i can hold it out in front of me
and realize that this isn't gonna kill
me this isn't gonna end me
yeah this isn't you know but this is
something that i have to deal with out
in front of me
then it becomes much more um possible to
be rational
and to think in terms of probabilities
and i've come to learn especially over
the last year or two
that when you can um make your decisions
based on probabilities of the outcome
you can make really really good
decisions yeah um
you know i was thinking a good example
of that is actually um
a friend of mine yesterday texts me and
he said to me
that it's interesting he said to me that
at his marketing agency
his clients passwords have maybe been
exposed to one outside individual
so there's one guy another company that
might have seen all of his clients
passwords
and he said steve i'm going to call all
of my clients now and tell them that all
of their passwords have been exposed
so i said let's go through the
probabilities here if you lined up a
hundred people
like the guy that might have seen these
passwords how many of them
would do something malicious with that
information we both agreed it was
probably less than one percent
of like reputable people that would take
a bunch of passwords and do something
malicious
so i said okay so one person out of 100
or less so your probability of harm is
less than one percent
um what's the probability of harm if you
call all of your clients and tell them
that
all of their passwords have been leaked
probably greater than one percent
yeah so let's think about ways we can
get that less than one percent down to
like zero so i said
email all your clients and tell them
you've done a security review
and that um you you highly recommend
they all turn on two-factor
authentication today
and that means the probability of harm
goes from less than one percent to zero
and but he was like in the in the
emotional mindset he was just like i'm
going to call them all yeah apologize
because you probably felt a duty of care
but if you do the two-step
authentication i suppose you're still
it's like you zero yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah music to zero percent
it's a duty you're balancing their duty
of care and you know how do i
remove harm from my clients but also
remove harm from my business but he was
so emotional when he called me
that he wasn't thinking rationally yeah
and that's why holding it out in front
of you allows you to think in terms of
rational employment
perspective that perspective is so
important to have like
i've always had like this irrational
fear of imminent disaster
so when i was a kid i used to come in
from school my mom would go and walk the
dog and she might be 15 or 20 minutes
most kids would just watch cartoons
i would be like out the window after 10
minutes singing where's my mom
where's my mom and then these little
voices come in my head all maybe
something really bad's happened to her
maybe she's like slipped over and banged
her head and
or maybe she's lying in a field right i
might have to go and find one my mum is
and then she reappears i'm like oh thank
goodness
even now with my kids if i'm out someone
they go around the corner i don't just
think to myself i'll walk around the
corner and my kids will be there
until i can see my kids again and there
might be parents listening to this that
relate
the worst possible things that could
happen to one's children is a
is happening to my kids until i can see
them so i find myself like speeding up
or saying to my friends yeah hey let's
go and sit over here so we can keep
just literally so i can keep an eye on
the kids and then i'm a little bit of a
hypochondriac so i fear that and then
when my phone goes
and or someone sends me a message going
hey jake can we have a chat later like
it could be someone from
whisper or it could be someone from bt
sport or someone about the pod
i don't go yeah yeah cool i'll call you
later i'm like oh what could that be
my brain goes to worst case scenario and
i found myself really quickly going so
it's got a really important call to make
my heart's racing 10 to the dozen and
then as soon as i
if i find out what it is i'm like oh
thank goodness where does this come from
i don't know
because there is no skeleton in the
closet like a friend rang me the other
day
and the message that you gave me was
he's separating from his wife
which is massively sad but he rang me
and said listen i'm really sorry to call
you with this um
quite awkward news i'm immediately
thinking oh my goodness right
what on earth can this be but in my head
it's gonna end everything it's gonna
cost me my marriage my kids
my job my house isn't that ridiculous
but
i now have the perspective that i know
this is how i am i've had this since i
was like 11 or 12 years old
i know this is how i'm made so that is a
really powerful thing for me because i
then think
when i feel this feeling beginning like
when my kids go around the corner i now
say to myself listen
your kids are going to be fine playing
the other side of a tree
you know yourself well enough to know
that this is just a rational anxiety
it's your brain
and it's just playing a trick on you
that's all this is you talk a lot about
responsibility yeah
um there you just said this is how i'm
made yeah
that sounds like giving up
responsibility yeah yeah so
now i think i'm taking i yes you're
right you are totally right
but then i feel like i'm taking the resp
i'm slowly still learning even at 42.
i'm taking the responsibility back by
saying right i'm not going to allow
myself to get anxious about that
because i know what i'm like if i'm the
most chilled out person in the world and
i find a reason to be anxious maybe i
should be worried about that
i'm going to tell them about the lift
jake
so we're on the fourth floor here and uh
jake jake came up uh
knocked on the door looking pretty
sweaty and said uh i just took breath
he said i just took the stairs because i
opened the lift and i didn't trust it
this lift there's never been any
problems with it if you look at the
stats around deaths in lifts or things
you and me are not hanging out today
that seems somewhat connected to what
you're saying
yeah i think you're probably right yeah
maybe i should have taken the lift
because i know that everything will be
fine in the lift and i should know that
i'm a bit claustrophobic but
i think it just goes to show that again
and you've spoken about this so
powerfully over the years on your
podcast is that from the outside world
you look at someone like me and think
wow
a couple of kids few businesses great
house nice broadcasting career
what a lovely carefree life he must live
every day man is riddled with little
anxieties and little worries
um a few years ago probably almost to
the point of derailing as we've
discussed on your previous
podcast with me but now knowing myself
knowing yourself is so powerful because
only then
like can you love yourself you think
that's also somewhat linked that you
said earlier on about that comment you
read
where people are like jake you know you
shouldn't be doing a podca happy
podcasting sad times basically
yeah the fact that you remembered that
and you referred to it as hurting you
seems also somewhat correlated to this
yeah i think
i don't know i think it's a i think it's
a it's a fair point
i find that a harder thing to get i find
external criticism
is a harder thing for me to deal with i
find that more
i find that a more difficult um thing to
own in my head why
um i think because probably human beings
just want people to like what we're
doing
i mean i find it confusing as well
because i think if you're being offended
by
my high performance podcast like
wow that that shows the level of offence
that some people can take because i
really want i honestly
want it to just be a holy positive
experience from the moment that someone
clicks subscribe or starts listening to
the pod to the minute they leave i just
i just want people to be happier to get
takeaways to live a more empowered life
to go and be successful i honestly
believe it like
it comes you've got thousands and
thousands and thousands of reviews on
your podcast yeah it's rated five stars
people pour their heart out telling you
how much they love it how much value it
brings
and we're talking about this one guy i'm
a human i suppose am i
i think you slightly over index a little
bit in terms of caring about this stuff
though
and i i actually you know when people
asked you know what you're like after
meeting you i said he's just such a nice
guy such a good guy
and you are such a good guy and it it's
maybe that is part of i don't know is
that somewhat connected to
your i think so don't you think that
don't you think the two are completely
connected though that
if i wasn't the kind of guy that
genuinely wanted people to
you know be in a better place i wouldn't
give a [ __ ] whether someone said my
podcast was useless i'd be like well i
don't care anything i'm just doing it to
make some money
for me that podcast and i will openly
say this i've not made a penny from
creating and operating for an entire
year
and we talk all the time that this is
about the outcome not the income
and and i think the reason why it has
been successful
is that whether it's me or whether it's
damien or whether it's the guys that
help us to film and edit the podcast
together
all of us totally believe and buy into
what we're doing like i genuinely
think that it is what people need to
hear
because it is empowering people and do
great things who have been
you know a lot of my friends messaged me
after you had johnny wilkinson yeah
and they said that was [ __ ] weird it
was deep wasn't it i had to listen to
that back five times and i did the
interview
you know what was the remark i haven't
heard it what was the surprising
so the the bravery really from from
someone who
won a rugby world cup as a certain
person and now is a completely different
person
i mean i can give you like a sort of
salacious headline like he told us that
winning the rugby world cup
is no more important than doing the
washing up and the
the way that he squares that off in his
mind is he says what are you doing if
you're playing rugby
moving your body to achieve a goal what
you're doing if you're doing the washing
up
moving your body to achieve a goal and
if i make winning the rugby world cup
more important or to hold more value
than doing the washing up and i'm no
longer a rugby player what am i less
valuable because i'm no longer doing the
thing that was more important
that was the that is the sort of
sentence that he was
sharing with us which i think is
brilliant and brave and i can
relate to it and i and i can understand
it um
[Music]
but i think that for me the sort of the
real the real
revelation that came out of the johnny
wilkinson episode and what i really want
people to understand if they listen to
it
is that when you strip everything back
he is someone who has
totally changed from where he was when
he was conquering the world because when
he was conquering the world as a rugby
player
he thought he had to stress and struggle
and sacrifice
and fail and now he realizes that
stressing
and struggling and sacrificing and
failing leads to
more stress and struggle and sacrifice
and fail
and actually one of the amazing things
he said he said when i
released a book after winning the rugby
world cup i wouldn't be surprised if
there wasn't a spike in mental health
cases from people that read that book
because the book was saying
you've got a struggle you've got a
struggle you've got to you've got to
really
struggle in life to be successful and i
think that that is something that i
when we first started the high
performance podcast
i loved it when people spoke to me about
the battle and the struggle and the
strife and the sacrifice and the late
nights and the early starts
because i wanted people at home to go
yeah man i'm gonna work harder
i'm gonna commit more i'm gonna
sacrifice more
now i think that is so so so wrong that
is the total antithesis
of what i now the message i now want my
podcast to give to people
it's tough isn't it because it's hard to
find someone who's been
really successful at the very top of
their game whether it's business or
sport
hasn't done that yeah so i've contended
with this i've like contended mentally
with this idea as well
well again when i started putting
content out there especially when i was
really young like 18
i was bragging about how late i was
staying up i was like look at me at 4
a.m and i'm still working
and i was doing that because i was
trying to portray an image that i was i
don't know
a superhuman or something and my content
followed that theme
and then i got to the point where i
probably flipped the other way because
of public pressure and people's and the
the world now thinks that if you go on
the high performance podcast and say
hard work really really matters you will
take an l
you are an [ __ ] for saying that
because you're going to make people
depressed and anxious and you're a
hustle porn star
and then i got to another place which is
if it's the truth
it's the truth and i'm comfortable with
the truth and so
there's so many levels of nuance it's
like
the most successful people you'll
encounter at the very top of their
industries
worked like hell to get there yeah yeah
yeah
it's you know will smith you know
circlive woodward or um any anyone in it
that's a very consistent theme elon musk
right
but it but what i've come to do over the
years is detach that from happiness
first and foremost because it doesn't
necessarily mean they're happier
and then also redefine what success is
because success
can be being a great parent yeah or is
it to you then
i it has to be happiness i feel like
yeah that's my answer yeah
that has to be because you can still
have
the hard work and you can still have the
sacrifice
but you don't have the struggle that's
the that is the mistake i made i thought
the struggle was part of the hard work
and it was part of the early starts and
the late finishes and it was part of
sacrificing some things
that's what i thought the high
performance podcast was about but it
isn't you're totally right it's about
happiness and you can still
get up at five like i probably take too
much on
and i probably get up early than i need
to and i go to bed later than i need to
but i am so happy and that's what it has
to be
and it can't be happiness at the
detriment of others happiness yeah it
has to be
being happy content with yourself and
spreading that happiness and that again
is something that johnny wilkinson spoke
about which
for me has been one of the biggest
revelations being absolutely present
absolutely totally present so when i'm
here with you
my phone is down on the floor and it's
actually on silent but it should be off
because
i need to be totally present with you
right now
because what's happened is gone what's
yet to happen which is me going off to
do a game at bt sport
is a story i can write that in my head
if i like but i'm probably going to get
it wrong because it hasn't happened yet
exactly the way the day's going to go
so i need to like look you in the eye
right now and i can now promise you that
on this podcast
i am absolutely here with you and it
might be in half an hour i leave but
that's cool because
when then we're done and i'm then
traveling
and then i'm totally present and i'm
into that that is a really important
thing
that has again been a mindset change for
me on the high performance podcast and
maybe
now i sit and talk to you maybe this
whole thing is like a totally selfish
exercise for me because
i must have said four or five times that
this podcast has
rewritten the way that i see the world
and the way that i operate
and i think maybe maybe i want this
podcast
to be messages to my kids like i talk
already about my anxiety
probably another of my anxieties is how
much longer am i going to be on the
earth you never know what's around the
corner
i love the fact that if it all ended for
me as a walk out onto shoreditch
high street today and a car comes along
what
can my wife say to my kids that oh i
don't know my dad very well listen to
these 25 episodes listen to these 30
episodes of the high performance podcast
there's your dad that's him you walk out
here today then
yeah touch glass um and bus comes boom
yeah it's over what are the things you
you in
you would regret not having done more of
uh traveling with the kids probably but
they're only little they're only young
it's
such a hard question for me because
i think i think probably um
maintaining relationships with people
has always been an issue for me
because i i failed my a-levels as you
know at school so all my mates went off
to uni so that was kind of lost because
they went off having fun and i redid
them and then
i've always found that one of the issues
with trying to really be present
is that you're totally present in that
part of your world at that moment
and so i was then totally plugged into
life on children's bbc
and then i got this amazing opportunity
at formula one and i was totally plugged
into my life
in formula one and then i got you know a
big opportunity at bt sport and i had to
make that work so then i was totally
plugged into my new producers
and my my new colleagues and you know i
had a conversation with someone the
other day and they said you know like
who
you who are your real friends
it's a hard question that for me once i
moved beyond my wife
because i've got four or five mates who
i'm close
with but they're i would probably name
people that live on my street well i've
only lived there for four years
i might name a couple of parents on the
school run my kids have only gone to
that school for four years
i'd name a couple of people i've run my
production company whisper with but
that's only been going less than a
decade
i'd now probably class damian hughes and
i do the high performance podcast with
well i've done that for less than a year
but i'm in this and maybe that is
possibly the only regret i think but
maybe i don't need
i don't know maybe we don't need to hold
on to people for too long maybe we have
to accept that people come and go from
our lives and that's okay
and do you think it's because you you
haven't sort of perhaps you said like
you haven't
prioritized investing in those
relationships as much
i think it's because i'm always too
invested in the thing that i'm doing at
that moment
like i am so absolutely committed to
whisper coral eyewear the high
performance podcast
bt sport my kids
my wife and my family
there isn't an awful lot left right i
guess the question the better question
to ask
would be then but you're are you happy
because that if that is the ultimate
goal
then you know society will tell you to
live have loads of friends and do this
and have this car and whatever but then
the question the most important is be
happy happiest i've ever been
i've been the happiest i've ever been
yeah so you've got to be doing something
right right yeah
i think yeah i mean i i love what i do
like i really
like work i like getting up early
i like having five or six things on the
burn all the time i like having a
whole page of jobs that i'm gonna do
other people are not like that my wife
is the
opposite she's got four or five jobs
she's like oh man i feel so stressed i
got
i don't want all this stuff whereas
sometimes i sit there and i'm not making
a list of
big things on the horizon and i'm i need
to have a lot of them
and again maybe i give a c to everything
and i'd be better to have fewer things
and give them more than an
a matthew mcconaughey tells a great
story about cutting off two of his big
businesses because he was giving a b
to five things and he wanted to be an a
in three things the guests you've had on
your podcast all these wonderful people
you've met
do you sometimes get the impression that
some of them aren't
that happy yes
yeah um it's one of the things i've
learned from doing this as well
yeah it's really interesting and and i
totally get that everyone is
everyone is in it for different reasons
aren't they
like we spoke to sean wayne who and i
would say
you know sean wayne is not a household
name he's one of the most successful
rugby league managers in the uk
but if someone wanted to get into the
high performance podcast and they wanted
like a first podcast to listen to
don't just go for the big names i'm
telling you now
sean wayne gave us the most moving and
revelatory interview and
he in his sort of broad northern accent
he said
you don't i'm not bothered about being
happy he said i'm not not
happy i don't care about happy and that
was not you know happiness was not his
thing he's con
as soon as he achieved something within
moments it's about the next thing
and we sort of broke it down that he was
very badly abused by his dad as a kid
you know physically
punched in the face by a big man often
and that his entire life his entire
energy comes from wanting to redress the
balance and he's now a rugby league
coach
the the england rugby league coach
because he
he has this deep-seated desire to make
the lives of other people better
now he might personally never be happy
after the story that and the path that
he's been through
but he's definitely making other people
happy and he is also
totally comfortable with not being happy
now that's not everyone's story that's
his story
um but i certainly think that
we like in the past we've thought that
success and happiness are mutually
exclusive what do you want to be here
and be successful you can be happy
how wrong are we to think like that the
very
flame of success should be happiness
that should be the
absolute nub the crux of everything
what's the point otherwise man
what is the point i i get that a lot
with guests that i've had on
they seem to some guests seem to be very
neurotically obsessed with
the next thing and the next thing and
the next thing in the next thing and
when you ask them to pause and reflect
on hey when this ends or
um or why they're doing it it always
seems to flick back to their childhood
eddie ham was the was the same um i know
he's been on yours he was on mine last
week
and he uh when i was talking to him
about his aspirations for the future
with matroom he says i want to sell for
five billion and
we'll do this and we're gonna there and
i said why do you wanna sell for five
billion you're happy now he goes
he goes well you know we should be doing
we could we should be selling five
billion that's why i want to do it
but why does that matter and he goes and
he goes back to his dad when he's
younger he goes back to the fact that
his dad
used to criticize him and didn't give
him praise and it's
and it's weird that those early moments
have driven so and it's the same with me
to be honest
they drove this like obsessive desire to
just keep climbing a never-ending
mountain
and that's the trend that i've seen in
very successful guests and very
successful people
is often some kind of
it's a strange thing to say but
something that went not to plan
yeah when they're younger seems to be
the reason that we all adore them admire
them it's something that had hit them
in their emotions or their wiring that
sent them into an obsessive state
in in never as good as you think it
would be though you know when you get
when you achieve those things that you
want to achieve like
the the biggest thrill i've ever had was
when i spent 9
750 pounds on a green mgf it's my first
ever car
i could still remember the number plate
njn and i looked at that car
i bought it from an elderly gentleman in
colchester and i went to his house
and i said i've got a banker's draft and
i was working on children's bbc
he took me out to his garage and you
know those old like um
fluorescent light strips they flicker
come on i remember it's still on my head
as vivid as the day it happened the
light flicking
and just lighting the car up for a
second and then it goes and i looked at
it and i was like
i cannot believe now fast forward to
where i am now
you know a successful tv presenter
invested in coral eyewear run a podcast
um have two beautiful children um
who have a production company the kids
and my personal relationships are aside
from this because that is that is on a
deeper level than anything else but in
terms of material successes
nothing and i mean nothing man nothing
has come close to spending less than 10
grand
on a green mgf so you've got to enjoy
the journey you've got to enjoy the
travel because a
it's not as good when you get there as
you think it will be b
you spend an awful lot more time getting
there than arriving
like you have to answer this totally
honestly
you have you've totally left social
change now yeah
with money in the bank yeah that you
wouldn't have had if you hadn't walked
away from that business right
yeah what is more thrilling to you to
look at your bank
account now and see the number in the
bank account or to know the journey you
went on the social chain
oh yeah of course i mean the bank could
be double triple quadruple
ten times it wouldn't matter now if i
said to you if i came to you in
manchester when you went to nab
frozen pizza just to feed yourself and i
said listen dude you can either
absolutely work your nuts off for the
next 10 years
like build a business hang out with
people develop some good relationships
or
i'll just bang 100 mill in your bank
account today
there you go yeah and now here you are
you've got 100 mil and the thrill came
from
the journey there's something like i'm
always conscious of my own like
hindsight bias
because it seems to be the case that
every
broke person um goes on the journey to
get rich you know
that ends up being successful they get
the money they go it doesn't matter but
it's a wonderful thing to say when you
have you right like
part of the reason it doesn't matter is
because there's so much of it now it
really mattered when i was stealing
those pizzas right and when i was like
going behind the sofas in this pub
looking for the pound coins and i found
13 pound coins so i went back the next
day and
like it really really mattered in fact
it was all that mattered you know
in that moment so i'm super conscious of
that bias that we have because
um and you should be by the way and we
we are the same
on high performance when i say or you
know you need to have the bad times to
appreciate the good times and
um the the the traumas and the difficult
things will
will equip you for the rest of your life
i honestly
know that there are people that would
listen and go hold on a minute middle
class
white guy from a lovely village in
norfolk yeah you've had a few
issues with mental health and bullying
and that as you know the death of my
grandma
which was quite tragic and things like
that you haven't really
struggled yeah so then i think it's
important that
we uh we've done an interview that we
haven't put out yet for the podcast with
ceo khaleesi
first ever black spring box captain
and he tells us a story in the podcast
about not being able
to sleep at night because his stomach
hurts so much because he was so hungry
so his grandmother
gave him sugar water just to get him to
school so he could have a day at school
and she died in his arms at eight years
old when he sits on the podcast
and says he will go through some really
dark and difficult horrendous times you
know he grew up
in the most deepest poverty you could
imagine in south africa when he sits
there and goes
you can get through it and you can use
it as a flame and a fire
that is i think when you listen um
it's um i i have to say i also
completely agree that uh
you know the things that have mattered
most to me professionally especially as
i reflect have been
doing as you say doing work i love but
then like doing it with people i love
um and a mission that's worthwhile and
there's just always
people talk about this topic of burnout
a lot um
and i tend to believe and i'd like to
get your opinion on this i tend to
believe that
your burnout is somewhat inevitable if
you're doing things
that you don't intrinsically love doing
especially if you're doing it with
people you don't
you know really really love as well and
i feel like in any facet of your life if
you're doing it
too much you don't enjoy it the outcome
is burn out
um but is burn out a topic that's been
sort of
prevalent on your podcast no you know it
i suppose
partly the reason why burnout hasn't
come up very often is because we're
talking to people who are in the midst
of their successes or who have been
successful
and they love what they're doing and
they love what they're doing they're
full of passion whereas
people who have perhaps tried to do
something that wasn't quite right and
have suffered burnout and it hasn't
worked
we we don't know about them because the
burnout ended the dream but it's so
funny that's such a good point
that the fact that your pod you haven't
had that come up as a topic on a podcast
that speaks to people
who have clearly been intrinsically
driven by their passion to the very top
of their game
passion is everything you know you say
you spoke to eddie hearn what's his
what's his podcast no passion no point i
mean he is a great advocate
of finding something that you believe in
but i also get that
again you had a real passion for what
you do like i honestly
like i have a such a deep love and a
passion for all the things that i'm
involved in because if i didn't
then i wouldn't do them or i'd try and
find something else but there were times
in my life where i've done certain
things like i don't
as a tv presenter you often get asked to
do like corporates you know standing up
at awards and things like that and you
you need to welcome people
on stage and shake your hands have a
photo and i
i find them a real struggle i don't know
why i just don't get
a thrill out of doing those things so
that's a good thing for me because i
i've noticed that's something i don't
like and that for people that are
listening to this thinking you know what
what's my passion like what am i one of
one of the
really good ways of finding you is to
look at all the things that is not you
who are the people that don't make you
feel good what are the days when you
feel
drained and exhausted what are the the
trips or the phone calls or the
conversations or the lunches where you
leave thinking
every time i see that person i feel like
this if you can see the
see the stuff that isn't good for you
and strip that stuff away you will
eventually
and it might take a while be left with
who you are and that's the time to
really then think right
what am i about what am i as a person
because
i don't think you you can obviously get
tired and you can be in and you can
have problems but i think with real
passion i don't think you suffer burnout
because every day i seem to get this
like
so you've not got kids yet right but
when you do you have argument you have a
beautiful feet remember when my daughter
was born i love her with every
piece of my heart right i had this real
fear that when my son was born
where's the love going to come from yeah
no you do there's a feed that is
it's a quite common thing for parents
like my daughter had every single
bit of love in my body so my wife
obviously would
we're really super close but love for
your child is so different
it feels very different from the moment
that child is born and i could not have
loved my daughter
not one percent more so then my son is
about to be born
my daughter's gone off to the
grandparents and i'm watching my wife in
labour thinking
i've got nothing left for for sebastian
what's this about
sebastian's born and within two seconds
i love him equally so there's no
diminishing of the love for my daughter
not one bit
but all this new love has just appeared
out of nowhere
and i could love my son exactly the same
how is that possible and it is exactly
the same when you have a real passion or
a real
love for something like every day that i
get up and i'm making
phone calls or i'm having conversations
or i'm you know brainstorming or blue
sky thinking or thinking about guests or
heading to do live television
it's all filler it's filled up again i'm
full i'm ready to go
you know i don't feel like i'm like the
cup is draining slowly
because i love the stuff that i'm doing
and that's a great point because i think
people tend to believe that
passion is a singular thing yeah and
then they're searching for it aimlessly
like it's an easter egg hidden somewhere
yeah
and that you can drain you can't drain
your passion yeah you can have multiple
passions
yeah and you know you've met a ton of
you know high-profile people on your you
know from your
from your presenting career but also
from your podcast i'm sure you've come
across a bunch of [ __ ] as well
yes i'm not gonna ask you to i'm not
gonna ask you to name them holly tucker
on her podcast came out with her you
know what it's like
she created not on the highstreet.com
she said i'd rather have a hole
than an [ __ ] in other words
i would rather hang out with no one than
hang out with someone that i don't like
which i
which i thought was uh which i thought
was a good one but then matthew
mcconaughey said
do you want an [ __ ] or an idiot give
me the [ __ ] because at least you know
where you stand
really yeah so he was like at least and
i i do
relate to that somewhat the people that
i really struggle with in my life are
the people who
one day you see them and they're like
your best mate the next day it's like
you've never met them before
i do struggle with that i i like to know
where i stand with people i'm cool
if you want if you and me want to have
like a distant professional relationship
and you'll send me a text
saying happy new year i hope the podcast
goes well maybe hook up sometime in 2021
and we never see each other socially and
you come back on high performance i come
back on here and we
use to and throw a bit professionally
that's absolutely
that is cool what i don't want is
hey let's have a coffee do you let's
meet up in london yeah great oh man it's
so nice to see you so how's things how's
life
we chat a bit more have you got a
partner how's your dog as your life
and then you hear nothing for six months
and you think whatever happened to that
dude
and then they reappear again i'm so
sorry for not texting you back
there's the truth i feel like you're
shouting um there's the
there's the difficult thing for me not
knowing where i stand with people i you
know i don't want to be everyone's best
friend but i do want
meaningful relationships with people and
they can be meaningful
from a distance or super intense
on that point of arseholes as well i
think um what made you what made you ask
that
i just i just one of the things i i
could you know what it is i remembered
one day
you meet a lot of people and when you do
this podcasting thing and you you have
an initial perception of how they're
going to be
and then you meet them and sometimes you
know sometimes they're souls i actually
don't think i've had anyone on the
podcast that was an [ __ ] but i have
had experiences
i remember this one day i got in this
plane i think i was flying emirates or
virgin or something
um and in front of me i saw that guy
from
the food guy the guy that eats all the
food on tv someone give me his name oh
um
yeah yeah yeah yeah um everyone in the
podcast
man versus food guy yeah man versus food
i mean i don't know his name
yeah and i don't care about saying this
um and we
run this huge food channel at social
change so we have you know tens of
millions of followers on a food channel
so i text the food team and i'm like oh
my god he's on the plane they said i'll
go up go up and ask him a question which
is a question we always ask us
on our food channel so i went over to
ask him this question
he was sat in um business i sat in
business as well
and he's just he just he looks at me and
goes
listen give me a second okay and i'm
like whoa
so i walk back to my my chair and i have
to tell the 500 people
in this like company group oh so i went
up to him and this person that you all
absolutely love
i've he's just cussed me out um and he
will never know the impact he had
on me or the 500 people that i then told
and also the you know
hundreds of thousand people that i'm
telling right now um if you got to the
point though where you're brave enough
to call that sort of stuff out
because i think that is the important
thing when he's when he does it
to his face yeah for me that would be
like
ego because you go from you yeah it
would be like do you know who the [ __ ] i
am or it'd be like
why are you saying that for me the piece
was like
no reaction yeah because there was no
win there was no win
in me calling him out i wasn't going to
win so the win for me was saying okay no
worries and we're going back to my chair
and also not letting it ruin my day um
but
but i'm sure you the reason i asked you
the question is because you have tons of
guests
in your presenting career but also your
podcast when you encounter an [ __ ]
um i guess how'd you deal with it
you just know that you're there for a
stop and not stay i think and you
um does it break your heart a little bit
sometimes
um when it's someone that you uh admired
yeah i suppose so i suppose i don't
worry too much about it because i just
think you know what
you can you're just not for me and also
like
who am i to sort of judge whether their
behavior is arseholery if it's clearly a
rude and unfair and unkind absolutely
i i now feel like i'm 42 and i'm a
parent
and i want my kids to operate in a world
where
um they can be themselves and they can't
be
bullied or pushed around i think we're
i'm old enough now and i definitely
wasn't like this a few years ago where i
can hold my chin
up and say that behavior is really not
acceptable would you call someone yeah
you would but i wouldn't do it in an
arrogant look at me i'm a being a dick
where i just say listen
i just think that behavior isn't
acceptable and have you done that um
yeah
to someone someone i work with you
in your presenting career uh yeah name
and address
and actually do you know what you find
is that often i've done it twice and
both times they've gone
yeah i'm really sorry that is actually
unacceptable i mean we
we had an interesting experience because
my wife used to work in production
so heard she was a production secretary
which is not very high up the ladder of
people in television and i was a
presenter so
she would be looking after security
taxis
tickets logistics clothing
call times all the stuff that makes
television happen
but is not the glamorous side and the
number of times
i would say i met this person today
aren't they great and she'd be like
really and then we would meet those
people
and i'd be like oh yeah i think you know
my wife harriet
and they were like oh right yeah hi
because they would be you guys love to
come around sometime for some food and
harry's like that's
not how they were really when they
thought i was just sorting out their
travel
and that is the definition of an article
yes i think it is because you just treat
everyone the same man
and they're treating you well because
you can potentially benefit them in some
way
i don't know it's weird isn't it like
why i've got a job on the television why
treat me any differently because you're
all connected and you can
that is what really annoys me we see
that and i saw that in my business over
the years and i
i came to believe that even with me
leaving the business it won't break the
business
but i do believe that like so i believe
one person leaving a business doesn't
break it and you can apply this to your
relationships your life your friendship
circle
but an [ __ ] staying can me leaving
the business i don't actually think will
be as detrimental to a couple of
[ __ ] staying in the business not
that there are any but
um i know what you mean yeah don't you
think though
like this is like it sounds naive and
churlish and a bit
childish probably from a 42 year old
bloke that has a
decent career and runs a few businesses
but like i honestly think that we
do have the power to make the world
positive and happy
despite all the issues because all you
have to do is worry about your immediate
circle
and that is why i get frustrated with
people who spread negativity and
criticism and i just i've just got no
space in my life now for negativity from
people
because i just think if let's say that i
know seven people
and i just say you know i'm gonna really
radiate
a positive energy i'm gonna lift them up
i'm not gonna be critical i'm gonna do
everything i can to make them feel like
a million dollars
the only agreement is that they have to
do the same
and you say that to those people listen
i'm going to do this thing i'm going to
be really super positive and i'm going
to do everything i can to help you and
if you ever need something i'm going to
be the person that comes and helps you
out
all i'm asking is that you do it for the
people in your circle
be the change see how quick that would
radiate yeah so my seven
so if i go if each of them goes to seven
you know what i mean yeah no
and it just feels stupid doesn't mean
that's that's what karma is yeah you
know i don't believe in wishy-washy
karma isn't like oh if i help a lady
then someone's going to help me in the
future but i think
from a logical perspective if i help
everyone i encounter maybe they'll be
more helpful
and that can make its way back around to
maybe my niece
you know but you know so true i just
i can't see any i can't see any benefit
any benefit to criticism and negativity
and like
driving other people down someone that
get feels better for driving someone
else further down
is like for me the absolute epitome they
are the worst of them do you ever get
jealous
be completely honest uh yeah um
i get jealous but i only ever get
jealous through comparison and that is
ridiculous you know it's the nasty is it
the nasty jealous where you're like
why have they gotten yeah probably yeah
yeah but you've got but
i think that is innate i think that is
almost there i am giving up
responsibility again for someone that
talks about 100
responsibility but i think that it's
innate in human nature
to to compare and to contrast and look
at someone else
so it's not a very long experience for
me i will look at someone
and i'll go but hey listen i'm so happy
and i've got all this i'm gonna and
actually sometimes i look at life as a
graph
and you literally don't know where life
is gonna take you so let's say like
the people that i now sit with in a tv
studio
like um i sit with they say when i when
i had
robin van persie stephen jarrod and rio
ferdinand were all the pundits on bt
sport
there was a time where all three of
those were three of the most famous
footballers in the country
earning phenomenal sums of money
competing on the world stage
representing their country
and i was a a guy post
a level failure trying to sort of find a
job and earning six thousand pounds a
year and there was a time where they
were there and i was there
and our graphs over the time have done
whatever's happened
look where i've ended up sitting next to
them on a tv studio
now it may well be that they go up there
again and something happens to me and i
go down here or it might be that i do
that and they do that
but you never know where that graph is
going to go and that is what i think is
that for me is one of the most exciting
things about this world that we live in
like you are only one step away from a
phone call where someone goes hey guess
what
and your graph goes so don't worry about
where other people are on that graph
because it might be in five years time
you're right alongside them
i guess that's where that that hate a
lot of the hate comes from so if you
take the jealousy feelings that even you
have as you know one of the nicest
people i know
and you just you know times it by ten
but you know and that's the
you know people feel a certain way about
their lives and how their lives are
going
that's because it's it's chucked in our
faces all the time
yeah what is instagram if it isn't a
tool for comparison what is it
why are you having a great day and we i
and i'm we're jealous of that i'm not
jealous we're guilty of it making other
people jealous of what we do
but we went out for uh we went for a
couple of days away as a family to a
lovely hotel called clifton
and it was lovely but the kids for some
reason were just badly behaved and it
does happen sometimes and we had this
meal
it was breakfast actually and they were
like it took ages for the food to come
and
the kids were like climbing the wall and
that's having to say to the waiter at
least i'm really sorry but like we've
been waiting for 20 minutes which is
fine for me and my wife but the kids
yeah they need and it was a posh hotel
where you're trying to said you get to
just stay at the table sit and sit
nicely don't make too much noise
and then at the end of it i was
stressful man and i said hey i'll tell
you what the family
will want to know where we are so i'll
get my phone out and i go kids kids just
smile
and we take a photo and we put it we
have a family what's up group with
harriet's mum and dad my mum and dad all
the cousins all the aunts and uncles
right
we're all smiling everything looks great
just had a lovely breakfast at the hotel
i said
and then then we get loads of messages
back like from people like my sisters
are going oh you're
your life always looks perfect and my
brother going oh another great day for
you
and i think actually yes like i've just
given them an absolute
falsification of what my sunday morning
cleveland house was like
that was a stressful hour and i've taken
the one thing that wasn't stressful
why have i put that in the group why
haven't i just gone hey guys hope you're
having a good sunday call we've just had
a [ __ ] half an hour here having some
breakfast but hey don't we all
that's and that's what we all do all the
time why else do all the people you
follow on instagram
put the things they put out there i i've
you know i think the world has somewhat
flipped is flipping back the other way
in the sense that when we
all started instagram it was this new
thing you had these filters and it was
like a show
the best holiday you've ever had in your
life to the world that was kind of the
that's the thing you'd get the rewards
for and that represents
in terms of being able to relate to that
or it's like
0.00 of the viewer's life like most of
our lives the 99 of our lives as i've
said in this podcast before is like
eating the pot noodle in bed
and now i see that the win with personal
branding and building
um an instagram page is the antithesis
of showing that it's like
i've just woken up with my face covered
in spots in fact the last
you know two podcasts ago we had
christian here who's like a superstar
influencer entrepreneur and i was trying
to understand why her community
are so engaged with her so engaged with
her
versus even like even compared to mine
or other people's and it's because she
wakes up in the morning she goes
my face is covered in spots oh my god
i'm not gonna put the filter on today
and you see the spots on her face and
stuff like that and then she'll cry
on her instagram story because her you
know her best friend lost her mother and
you
really can resonate with that you can
and also the amount of supply
on social media of that realness is low
demand is super high because it
represents the 99 of our lives
supply is super low and uh and
people joe wicks is the same he he will
he will
tell you everything i feel like [ __ ]
today you know and people just
and that's the thing i think you can
form a bond with a real deep bond
so even as i reflect on my instagram now
i said to my team earlier this week i'm
like i need to like go on my instagram
story more
and do a lot of the stuff that i do on
the podcast which is just like telling
you the [ __ ] stuff too yeah
um and so i i say this yeah if you want
to build a personal brand i'm like you
know
you really need to get comfortable with
that make you happy though let's go back
to where we began
would you make me happy yeah because i
know
that it would not make me happy i my
instagram isn't a lie
it is real but it's real with the things
that i choose to share basically yeah do
you know what i mean
by the way i have no lunch can i knock
yourself down it's actually yeah
this one actually worked this month so
it's um what is it this one this is
not had one present for you though when
i saw that you've got huels
yeah it's just great i was panicking i'd
undone it and i was going to flip fuel
all over your lovely rug in here
doesn't matter that that would be a cool
piece of promo um nutritionally complete
drink yeah yeah yeah
i think it's great man so i've eaten
nothing today what's the time it's
vegan 20 past one so this is perfect for
me now this is my lunch
and my breakfast try let me know what
you think
this is my favorite flavor of all
that's good and if you have this all day
um which i don't know if that's to be
recommended but
all of your sort of essential minerals
are in there vitamins
high in protein so it's 20 grams of
protein at the same time slow releasing
carbs spill a bit on your really lovely
glass table it's fine don't mind
low sugar gluten free yeah it's great
that's nice it's lovely yeah
and i drink it because um because i skip
meals
that's how i first well i'm trying to
intermittently fast because i've seen
um other people's six packs on social
media and they make me feel at me
okay they make me feel like i just need
to
you know right why do you feel the need
to share more of yourself on instagram
like so yeah so what's the benefit the
benefit is if i share
more of my truth all the the tough stuff
which is pretty much why i started the
podcast in the first place
i feel that i'm helping a lot of people
and do i enjoy helping people and
getting
um and helping them overcome their
problems yes
yeah i mean you do that already on this
podcast yeah but i don't do it on
instagram
and i i think that do i want to have a
deeper connection with my audience on
instagram
yes what am i doing on instagram
predominantly just posting quotes to be
honest
so if i want to have a deeper connection
with my audience on instagram then i
should go deeper with them
yeah as i do on this podcast because the
podcast audience are like a cult
you know they're super engaged because
of the depth and the realness
so i think it would make me happy in the
long run there must be a reason i don't
do it
that's a good point this i mean it's
been a huge revelation for me doing a
podcast because
when you're a football presenter you
don't get nice messages
on instagram you don't get like an
engaged core saying
this resonated with me that resonated
with me partly because you're not the
story
you're there to facilitate former pros
to be the superstars i mean i liken my
job on the football to like being a
referee
like if i'm not seen that's probably a
good thing i make them look good i make
them feel good
and people let's be totally frank tune
in to watch the game
more people will tune in for man united
the more tuning
for norwich city more people won't
tune in for me because i'm just
the facilitator whereas with the podcast
the nicest thing has been this genuine
conversation connection like creation of
a
proper community and that's that's been
a totally new thing to me i thought i
knew everything that was to know about
broadcasting and
you know with a million followers on
twitter and an instagram account and
running a tv production company and
being a tv presenter like i knew what it
was about i knew how to connect to
people
i've never known anything like it never
seen feedback like
it never had fulfillment like it
it's amazing is there something crazy
about podcasting though versus all other
channels and i think it's that depth
the messages you get if i post something
on instagram i'll get a
oh i can totally relate the podcast you
get a
like essay about you know they return
with their story
yeah and it's like depth begets depth
yeah yeah
yeah i totally see what you're saying
and i and it's um
it stops it from like because when i
first started the high performance
podcast i wanted it just to be
me opening up amazing people to benefit
other people
and i will now admit part of the thrill
of that podcast is seeing the response
and seeing
seeing the reaction and i'm i'm not
foolish enough to think that isn't my
ego at work it absolutely is my ego that
likes it
but it is like it's amazing when you see
hi i listened to your podcast and i
changed jobs after wanting to do it for
20 years hi i listened to your podcast
and i've quit doing something that's
been bad for me for my whole life
i've reached out to create relationships
with people that are allowed to die
from listening to our podcast bloody
hell
what's the most emotional moment you've
had with a guest that you can recall
on the podcast is there a particular
moment that you know yeah who
there's quite a few times that i've kind
of um
that i've sort of edged towards tears
and i think you know someone i've
already mentioned
sean wayne you know when um when someone
talks to you about
that sort of the devastation of being
physically abused by a parent and
they've got
i suppose what was emotional for me was
the was the learning
during the interview with sean and i
knew very little about him before we
spoke
the learning that all of the good stuff
he's done you know he talks about
if he's got an issue with one of his
players he doesn't just have to chat
with him after training he turns up at
their house in the evening he says
what's the deal man
how can i help how can i solve this um
and he is now a parent himself and a
really loving and caring parent to have
the start in life that sean had
and to for your whole life to be about
helping other people that was like
that that was a that was a hugely moving
conversation with him
yeah i think all of all of the guests
i've had that have um moved me in the
same way
is almost identical it's nice isn't it i
don't know whether you're like this with
podcasts but
i love that we have footballers on and
don't talk about football
we have rugby players and i don't really
talk about rugby
um we just talk about it
my podcast is a podcast about life
exactly like this one is
and we were talking before we started
recording today about the
the desire to try and avoid the typical
talking points with guests
and i think this is maybe just a general
a general point for people that are
trying to start a podcast you know
um there are so many podcasts out there
yeah and
in order to what would your tips be then
for someone who's considering starting a
podcast from what you've learned in your
30 or you know
you've you've recorded a total of 50 so
far but yeah we've done that live
what tips what did you give to someone
who's thinking of starting their own
first of all go for it
because i honestly what i honestly
was this close to not doing it the great
thing about podcasts that you
that i didn't have in my life was
ownership so i'd spent my career
working for children's bbc working for
formula one
and the bbc working for the premier
league on bt sport
and i sat down with someone they said
like how's your career and i said yes
great
i'm really happy i love doing the
football i love being with the players
and everything and they said what
if you've got a phone call tomorrow to
say that that had ended what would you
be left with
and i was like um today i have to go and
find another job
they said so what do you own of all
these years of graft and hard work like
what's yours
and the answer was nothing and then the
next question they
you know they obviously knew what they
were talking about i said what do you
really want to do
and i said well i don't really care
if liverpool beat man united or
norwich city be ipswich not really but i
love like the effort and the graphs and
i love sitting with the pundits i love
the way that
rio ferdinand and steven gerrard watch a
game of football i love how they turn up
looking smart or they bring their own
food in little
plastic containers still or the day that
i first met lewis hamilton
and he walked in the room and he like
took off his watch
and he didn't just chuck his watch on
the side he got it and he closed up the
clasp
and he put it down and he moved it and
he goes
bracelet off and he went
[Music]
i just looked at i thought ah that
desire for perfection that elite mindset
mentality i said to them that's what i
want i want to
speak to elite performers and elite
thinkers
because i think that everyone can
benefit from that everyone can think
and operate and perform better because
there's no tricks there's no secrets
like
you just need to have the passion and go
out and do it
and they said well then that's what you
should do a podcast so that was it right
great i'm doing a podcast
and then i mentioned it to a couple of
people and they went why you can't do a
podcast
i was like why because everyone does
podcasts like there's literally so many
podcasts
you can't you're not gonna make a splash
there's thousands of podcasts
and then i rang an old friend of mine
from children's bbc and she is
i don't really even ever told her this
but she's the reason i do the podcast
fern cotton who does happy place i said
hey
i think i'm doing a podcast now she is
such a nice person she is not the sort
of person to go oh hold on
a rival podcast yeah she'd never even
consider she would oh my god you'd be
great at doing a podcast
like she spoke about what it was about
and i said but my issue is i just think
that like there's loads of them out
there
and then she was the one that said look
we worked together at children's bbc
yeah
television had been invented for 50
years there must have been
hundreds of channels thousands of
programmes did you think i'm not going
to work in telly because there's already
loads of tv programs no course you
didn't you just thought well i'm gonna
work in telly and make my mark
she said you need to do exactly the same
thing with your podcast
um so the first thing you is you have to
do your podcast you have to go out and
do it
but the second and that's the biggest
challenge though isn't it
starting it's just in every facet of
life yeah entrepreneurs contact me and
i'm like the biggest risk you face
of all the things that might yeah i
think you can do a podcast risk-free
though you know you can spend a very
minimal sum of money if any money at all
on on the equipment 100 but then you can
you can so cheap yeah no you could start
you could do a great podcast in terms of
sound quality with
less than 100 pounds yeah the risk
though
is overthinking it to the point of
procrastination to the point of select
paralyzing yourself
i think in all facets of life business
my dm's are full of people that are like
steve i want to start a business i have
an idea i want to start a podcast or
this project
but there's just this one problem which
is preventing me starting and i always
say the biggest risk
of the success of your business the
number one thing that's going to stop
you becoming a billionaire honestly
is the probability that you'll just
never start and also
that you'll think you need all of the
answers to all of the questions you have
before you start yeah
well i don't know this i don't have the
funding i don't like when i started my
business i was 18 didn't know the word
entrepreneur
no money went on google and typed in
like
how to build a website spent three
months googling it but that was me
starting
you know um and i think it's the same
with podcasting i'm like
my first episode was dog [ __ ] i was
downstairs inside
what is it when telly would say the
first is the worst you know that's the
way it is that's the way it has to be
but the point is
you got going you started and i think
you need to begin
and then you need to be consistent and
you need to keep going and don't expect
instant success and instant
gratification but i think the other
thing for it like i get a lot of
i get a lot of people sending me letters
saying i want to be on the television
and i always reply in the positive
because i always say well someone has to
be doing my job
in 20 years time when i'm 62 i will not
be presenting the premier league on bt
sport
i just won't be someone has to be could
be you why not make it you make the
decision now that it's going to be you
that's the next
well-known sports tv broadcaster and
then i remind them that
when i started out in 1998
99 to be on the telly to be a
broadcaster you actually needed a job
that was not very easy to go and get now
you can pick up your phone
and you're a broadcaster you can have a
youtube channel you can have an
instagram handle
you can have a twitter page you can have
a podcast
as long as you've got a passion because
you then funnel
everything into that passion and
everything feeds everything else so the
instagram handle points people towards
the podcast the podcast is fantastic so
people go and watch
the podcast that you've recorded on
youtube and then you start to build an
audience there and you make a little bit
of money and it slowly starts to build
be consistent but have the passion have
the thing that's different like
i will get maybe 10 times a week hi jake
um i just wonder whether you would come
and be on our podcast we just want to
talk about you know your journey and how
you got to where you are now it'd be
really great to have a chat
and you roll your eyes and it's like man
you've got to be better than that
everyone can go and have a conversation
about your journey and the highs and the
lows and the struggles
what's the niche what's the team yeah so
tell me anything tell me what someone
would have to say to you that has
basically no listeners or is starting
out that would make you go on their
podcast because like passion would be
absolutely
definitely about their passion and i
have done plenty of podcast interviews
in the last year
where there hasn't been a big audience
but i've really loved the fact that the
person has come to me
known a lot about me and said i really
want to explore
this particular area with you i think
just the broad brush stroke of can we
just talk about your inspiration and
talk about your upbringing
and talk about how you first got into
broadcasting
yeah let's like i'm a bit like this now
and everything i do like even when i'm
broadcasting
i'm not interested in canon united win
the league i am much more interested
in um looking at one of the players
marcus rashford for example and having a
really proper
deep conversation with paul scholes and
rio ferdinand like
explain to me how hard it is for him to
concentrate on football
when he's got so many people criticizing
him on social media for doing the school
dinners
or how difficult is it for him to
run out of old trafford and really
perform at a high level when he hasn't
got
80 000 people how much of a difference
does it really make to have the crowd at
old trafford they're
inspiring you and driving you on like
that is a
much much more of an interesting
conversation for me because it feels
much more real
yeah than just the general stuff so that
would be my advice to people is
make it really specific make it really
passion based
and there's that big about like having
you want them to
show evidence that they've done their
research on you so because
listen people send emails invite you
onto a podcast or dms whatever
but most of our lives um and the success
of our lives
as least as i can recount it in my
journey has been predicated on me
knowing how to ask someone for something
that they really didn't have a huge
clear incentive to give me yeah asking
in the right way so we're not just
talking about inviting jake onto
podcasts here we're talking about how
you ask for something
how you knock on a door that uh you know
maybe is a bit
above you at that point i think that
often you get a lot of respect there
just for asking the question
and i think i think the other thing is
for people to remember when they're in
our position
you've been in that position as well
like you have been there and don't
expect them to be perfect by the way
like everything that you now find easy
about sitting here and recording this
podcast once you didn't find easy
yeah you found it a struggle that's the
really important point
and those people are often right at the
beginning of their journey and they're
finding their way
and why can't you give them 10 minutes
even if you can't go on their podcast
stephen why can't you just go do you
know what just give me your number i'll
give you 10 minutes 10 minutes of your
day
is nothing could change your entire life
so there's a lot of people asking for 10
minutes this is the problem
and if you add it up there's then we
don't have much time left for anything
else and i i sometimes think to myself
if i gave all of these people 10 minutes
i wouldn't be the type of person that
they'd be asking for
you can't do stuff you don't have time
to do but you probably can do
10 minutes once in a while a couple of
times a day yeah
the thing that annoys me a couple of
times with the dm's the night once in a
while
yeah once a couple times a day yeah
anyway
yeah do you know i'm doing it anyway for
like i told you about my friend that
called me with a problem
like so i give him 20 minutes to solve
the problem with him i'm doing that all
day every day and
my employees all at social change now
that i've left contacted me more than
i think they did it when i was there
asking me how to solve problems
with each other with the company what
should we be doing so yeah i still feel
like i'm mentoring a lot of
people don't always look for like the
instant value and stuff
no i know that when someone rings you
and goes um stephen i know i'm a social
chain and i know i wasn't very high up
the chain at social chain but
and i know you've left i [ __ ] love
what you did a couple of quick questions
right
yeah you might look at it and go do you
know what i remember that person i just
haven't got the time i've got to get in
the gym
right let's say you did yeah what you've
done is you've seen the value to you
in that moment of giving them 10 minutes
of your time what about if that person
then goes on and thinks
wow i've been so impressed by what i've
done at social channel i'm going to set
up my own business i'm going to do this
and suddenly the snowball effect comes
and then in a couple of years time you
get the phone call steve and i'd love
you to be on the advisory board of this
business i set up because i actually set
it up because you gave me a bit of
inspiration a few years ago
there's the value you never see it's
invisible if you don't give them the few
minutes at that time
i call it hand it out man invisible pr
yeah
you never see it in the moment you never
see the impact it's having but when it
matters the most
it will show up so for example the guy
told you about from man vs food
we have a huge food channel and we're
looking for hosts for this food channel
that would potentially get paid a ton of
money
and in that one moment he will never see
he saw the value giving you
10 seconds in that moment and then with
no value yeah but but now
he's clearly going to be excluded from
the process of deciding who hosts the
food channel yeah just because of that
10 seconds
he'll never know because it's invisible
pr um but what i see what does make me
annoyed is i'll get messages from
someone and i'll say steve
i swear to god i got this message i
screenshotted and said it's my friends
because it
it's synonymous of the wrong approach
steve um
i'd love to know uh how you did what you
did
i've produced thousands
of videos podcasts interviews
blogs on how i did what i did there's
actually a video called like how i
built a 200 million company or whatever
and for me when someone says that i
think
you don't actually want to know because
if you really wanted to know you would
have put that into google yeah or you
would have put more effort in
you're being super lazy and then i said
to the guy i saw it
you're not fine got the video where i
explained how i didn't i did what i did
and i sent it to him he goes uh you know
you should write a book
i
maybe he just doesn't yet know what he
doesn't know
and if you showed him these these little
bits in 10 years time he'd be
embarrassed and maybe if you looked at
some of the
early interactions you had with people
you'd be embarrassed about what you i
know i would some of the emails i sent
i've
i so i have a really old hotmail account
that i've had literally since the
beginning of time and i don't use it
anymore
but sometimes it's quite cathartic for
me to go back into that hotmail account
zoop back to the very beginning we're
talking about emails i was sitting in
2001.
and i'm surprised man i get my tone
wrong and i'm a bit bulshy and i'm a bit
pushy and i think this doesn't sound or
seem like me
maybe i just think benefit of the doubt
man
always benefit of the doubt and i'm not
saying you need to bust your balls
and spend two days giving this person a
private seminar
but definitely do i mean i think it's
great you replied and just reply go
listen
here's all the stuff that i've done but
when he replies and says
you should write a book a he's giving
you a compliment
b he might be a bit nervous you know the
problem is so there's thousands and
thousands of people
like this on a weekly basis yeah so my
my decision as to who to
help or to who to engage with is based
on the message they send
and if someone says some people would
message me go so um
so what is social change come on like if
you just googled it yeah if you
if you clicked on the word in my bio
there's a description of exactly what it
is
but people will still and for me that's
laziness because if i like i can't think
of a point in my life where if i wanted
to know
whether i was 16 or 26 whether if i
wanted a piece of information
i would have just my my attempt at
getting it would have just been to
message the person you know the public
figure whatever you say so uh
how did you uh win that uh formula one
championship lewis
i would have at least tried you know
what i mean do you think there's an
issue here with um
like with a social media now there's a
complete lack of formality so like when
you and i were growing up and we wanted
to run a business that someone had set
up and sold for hundreds of millions you
literally could not get to that person
unless it was a real graft to get there
so by the time you did manage to get an
email address for some ceo of some big
business
it had been such a journey you weren't
going to lose the opportunity or waste
the opportunity
because it had taken you two or three
months just to get to the point of being
able to send something
part of the issue now is the people who
want information from you
literally this is how long it takes
steven bartlett
direct message h-i-s-t-e-v
hi steven um can i know about your
business
right that's taken me 30 seconds that's
how long it is so that's why
the quality of effort is so low because
because they're just
used to it that's how we now communicate
with each other but then the other thing
is
20 years ago when you were trying to get
hold of a ceo of a big business
there was quite a good filtration
process so that by the time you got the
email address of that guy
or that woman at the top of that
business it was a journey
you would have had 20 knockbacks 10 or
15 setbacks blah blah blah blah blah
so actually the person that got those
email addresses were
the grafters man and the ones that were
finding the route and finding the path
and it shows though that the most
important thing one of the
2020 growth hacks for your career is
knowing how to ask
yeah because everyone everyone has now
got the email or the dm
but there's a real art in knowing what
to say when you're in there
i know that people like you are getting
a lot of messages every day
all of the same quality but that's great
because it's easy to stand out if you
want to say a good thing
if you send me a voice note that jumps
up in the queue
if if the voice note is um well
researched as you say jumps up in the
queue further
if you're asking here's the thing for me
it's like if you're asking me for
something
and you're making some attempt to
acknowledge the fact
that um that you know i don't have a lot
of time that also jumps up in the queue
because i think you this person's a
little bit more you know savvy and
it's being more realistic um but yeah it
makes a huge difference
coral yeah i want to talk about this so
i eyewear brand i received these lovely
um sunglasses
in the post and as i said to you before
we got on out i'd usually look a little
bit
weird in sunglasses but this pair of
sunglasses and i'm not just saying this
and i actually said this behind your
back as well so this is how you know
it's legit right
um i actually think i look quite cool
you do look good yeah and i would never
wear
sunglasses like this normally because i
couldn't find
the right shape yeah tell me all about
coral and and what this is this is your
first sort of significant investment
yeah it's the first time i've ever
invested in a business really obviously
whisper group is different because i was
a founder and we set that up together
um but i've wanted for a long time to do
what i can
to help people who are perhaps in a
position where i can have some influence
on their lives so
about a year ago i set up a scholarship
with the uea the university of east
anglia in norwich
it's pretty simple when people apply for
the film and tv course
they're means tested so they have to
fill in a form so we can find out their
family income and if the family income
is below a certain level
i will pay five grand a year every year
that they're at university so 15 grand
over the time of their course
to make it affordable for them to go to
uni so it's literally my way of finding
people
who wouldn't get a chance in the tv
industry it's similar to the ethos we
have at whisper like we want to lift up
people that are underrepresented and i
think there's amazing tv talent out
there
and they literally will never get the
opportunity to have a tv career
purely for financial means and that
really makes me sad
so i set that up and then i had this
great relationship with the uea and they
introduced me to a
young guy called george bailey and he's
a 19 year old student he's 20 now at the
uea
and he had this idea for recycled
eyewear and it is literally taking
fishing that's out of the sea
taking plastic out of landfill and
turning them into eyewear
and ice and i said you know what george
like that's a really good idea
i really like it but it will be
everywhere already because it's so
simple
because when we sort of run through the
numbers there's something like nine
million
pairs of eyewear sold in the uk every
year almost all of them virgin plastic
covered in lacquer full of glue full of
metal
bad for the environment not doing any
good for the planet at all
so i sort of heard what he said and
thought this would be happening already
and i was actually in london for a
meeting with my agent in west london i
thought the perfect place
for recycled sustainable eyewear brand
is west london
so i went into all of the high street
eyewear places that you could possibly
imagine
you know david klullo and um sunglasses
hut and all of these others on oxford
street and bond street i was in that
area and i said
the same thing every time i walked in hi
can i see your range of recycled eyewear
blank faces can i see your green range
your sustainable range
the same nothing response and i was
straight on the phone to george i said
listen
we need to make this happen we really
need to make this happen and we're not
the only brand in the world
making eyewear from recycled material
but we're the only brand who have gone
and got our own eyewear designer so it's
original designs
handmade in a factory in italy we then
offset
all the carbons when that gets delivered
to you there's not been a single
hit on the planet from the carbon and
the plastic has been taken out of the
world to create those
the lenses are infinitely recycled and
we have a system where you send the
lenses
or the whole eyewear back to us and we
can recycle them so it all goes again
so the phrase i use is planet positive
it's not just like not putting pollution
into the planet it's actively removing
plastic and turning it into something
that you would otherwise have gone and
purchased
um and look we're a startup we're small
it'll be a slog
and it'll be a battle but i wouldn't
have got involved like everything else
i've been talking to you about if i
didn't passionately believe
that those are the answer none of us go
shopping now
without a plastic bag in our hand
already or a reusable tote bag or
whatever
but none of us think twice before we go
and buy a pair of sunglasses
and coral i wear i want to be the answer
the case there that's made from plastic
oh this case or this case yeah that's
recycled plastic the cloth inside
recycled plastic you'd never know would
you no even one of the things that
really struck me as well is how high
quality it all feels like it feels super
luxury like the
the case and then well that's the thing
we want we also didn't want people to
think yeah i want to sort of help the
environment but i'll have to look a bit
rubbish
we actually want people to think i can
still buy
a really nice high-end high-quality bit
of eyewear you got a little note there
from george yeah what's he said on this
says hey there thank you so much for
choosing coral and our vision to make
the eyewear industry kinder to our
planet
smiley face george that's super nice
yeah no i
i was you know i was i was nervous
because when friends send me things and
then he probably
sometimes i don't say yeah and i'm i'm
known for being really honest
with my friends um and saying oh i don't
really like this about it or whatever
because i just think the truth sets you
free
and that's what people really value as
you said earlier it's like the the
critique is often
um more valuable at certain stages than
just total praise one word you said
earlier that i
has become incredibly important in my
mindset these days is the word
consistency yeah
um maybe from meeting exceptional guests
maybe just from understanding
the root cause of my own accomplishments
but um
i you know i used to think that
intensity was was the answer but if you
look at all of the success that i've had
whether it's getting a million followers
on instagram or social channel whatever
it was it was that word and i never
really appreciated the importance of
that word up until recent i think when i
was writing my book
what have you learned about consistency
i've learned
exactly as you have that consistency is
the root
of all good stuff because if you find
something that works for you
you have to do it consistently like i
used to say consistently relentless
i regret the use of the word relentless
a little bit now i i do think you have
to be relentless
but i now change it to you have to be
consistently happily
relentless and if you can be
consistently
happily relentless i don't think you
will go far wrong because
you'll be doing a passion project which
is what makes you happy
you will be consistently doing things
and consistency is absolutely
key for people to understand what you're
about and let's be totally frank
we can sit here and be fluffy and
friendly and say oh you know let's not
push people too hard in the modern world
because it might cause issues and
whatever
you do have to be relentless
for success but it's okay to be
relentless
if you're being relentless and you're
happy being relentless
so try in 2021 to be consistently
happily relentless and let's see where
we all are in 12 months time
i have one more question for you it's
probably a question people don't really
talk about
in the podcasting game but um we have
struggled at times to get
women to come on the podcast yep
um for a variety of different reasons
men seem much more
willing than women have you found the
same thing yeah we have yeah it's
interesting you should say that yeah we
have
i don't think that we have found women
not willing to come on the podcast
i think it's only when you start doing a
podcast about
relentless high achievement that you
realize
how dominated by men
the tops of our industries are yeah
that's the problem
and i you know we keep on saying right
who should we get on as really great
inspirational female leaders and
all the suggestions people keep making
to us are in the sports space i keep
saying no not sports women
because we are totally i am totally
plugged into the fact that i want to
celebrate
brilliant successful females you know i
have a daughter and i want her to
listen to this podcast in years to come
when she's old enough and go that's who
i want to be that's what i want to be
inspired by
and i think that sometimes we like to
trick ourselves into thinking oh no we
live in a really equal society now what
are you talking about there's loads of
powerful females at the top of
businesses when you break it down
we are still in a male dominated society
and it's a good reminder that we need to
keep on lifting up
female role models and pushing them to
the absolute top and we are
on the high performance podcast we are
totally aware of that um and we will
continue to do what we can because
actually
when we get brilliant female leaders on
there and we just recorded
with joe malone um who set up the
amazing joe malone brand she now runs
joe loves we've recorded with
holly tucker who was fantastic dame
kelly holmes who was really
inspirational and moving steph horton is
going to be on
the series in the not too distant future
we've had
brilliant female
leaders on our pod but it is still
a challenge compared to the amount of
male leaders lining up going i'll
definitely come on there and talk
and there is something else that maybe
we need to address in the next 12 months
black women at the top of business mate
where are they
why what is happening that is not
allowing them to shine as they should
and that's one thing and i just say one
thing that really is pissing me off
massively at the moment
is when people talk about the
over-representation
of black and mixed-race or female role
models in society
and they say oh everywhere you turn now
you know that's all this and i
drive this home to the whole time i say
listen you've got this completely wrong
the reason why we now have to promote
and push and celebrate and shout
about black men and black women
and women in general and
underrepresented
areas of society is that if you are a
little kid growing up
in norwich or manchester or birmingham
or
los angeles you have to see those people
there to believe that you can get there
as well
there's no good saying oh yeah they'll
eventually make it through we have to
show them now
that you can no matter who you are no
matter what the color of your skin
no matter what your gender no matter
what your background no matter how
affluent you are
you can get there and that's why we have
to push them to the forefront now
to inspire the next generation because
once they're there they'll stay there
and it'll be a much better more equal
society for everyone
we've both got a big responsibility yeah
with our platforms yeah and it and we
should we absolutely should
listen thank you for your time no one
was incredibly busy it's always nice to
sit down
yeah thanks for lunch no it's always
fascinating and i
i you know you're discovering um
incredible stories through your own
podcast high performance and
it's uh it's really powerful to kind of
compare notes sometimes with with people
uh
because yeah my one of the things i've
learned from doing the podcast which i'm
sure you have as well is that
the themes that have made people
successful and giving them that high
performance mindset are actually quite
consistent yeah yeah yeah i think when i
started my podcast i was expecting to
find
50 different ways you know to become
successful but
it all seems to be distillable down to
these simple themes like
you know consistency and discipline and
passion and then
for me anyway much of the root cause of
that consistency or that obsession with
that passion has come from
often in many circumstances something
that might not have gone
right yeah on the playground or some
insecurity they had or something their
dad or mum said to them
um and that for me is fascinating but
yeah thank you again for your time it's
pleasure and um
it just reminded me that we're all on a
journey right and i said to harriet when
i was coming on here today i said oh i'm
going
back on diary of a ceo with steven
and she said again what are you going to
talk about because you only went on
there a few months ago
and you know when i now sit here and
talk to you i'm a different person to
the one that you spoke with before i
began
doing my podcast before i began doing my
stuff with coral airway even in the last
year i feel like i'm sitting here as a
different person
and i didn't realize that you could
learn and change and develop and adapt
quite so much quite so late so man look
joe biden
took him until he was 77 until he nailed
it as the president
you know sometimes you have to wait a
long time in life for your dream job or
your dream opportunity
what has changed since we last spoke for
you in terms of who you are just a much
deeper understanding
of how other people operate i hadn't
i've spent my life hadn't like on my own
journey me as a presenter
me learning me setting up a business
what am i gonna do
the high performance podcast was the
first time i'd ever sat down
and just said from the outside this is
what i think you're doing can you just
explain it please
what a growth period it's been for me
personally
absolutely unbelievable and therapy at
the same time right yeah it's
therapeutic
absolutely um
[Music]
foreign